بحر من الناس
يختبئون وراء الأقنعة الواقية من الأكتاف ، هذا
هو المشهد من معبر حدودي رئيسي
يربط بين البر الرئيسي للصين وهونغ كونغ
بالفعل قيود حدودية
لمنع دخول أي شخص من
مقاطعة هوبي ، بؤرة
فيروس ووهان القاتل.  واليوم
خاطب زعيم المدينة وسائل الإعلام معلنا عن
إجراءات إضافية بما في ذلك
الحظر الجزئي على النقل وتعليق
بعض الخدمات في محطات العبور الحدودية ،
وسنقلل بشكل كبير
من تدفق الأشخاص بين
المكانين ،
لكن العديد من نقاط الدخول مع
البر الرئيسي لا تزال مفتوحة.  هنا عند حدود
لو وو التي تعبر أحد المعابر الحدودية العديدة التي
تربط هونغ كونغ
والبر الرئيسي للصين ، وبينما يطالب العديد من
المسؤولين الطبيين والمشرعين
بإغلاق الحدود
تمامًا حيث يمكنك رؤية الأشخاص
من البر الرئيسي يواصلون التدفق
في أعقاب  السنة القمرية
الجديدة وهذه مشكلة لبعض الناس
مثل المشرع في هونج كونج مايكل تي
عندما يبدو أن لديهم إغلاقًا كاملاً
للحدود البرية والبحرية
، يقول إنه يجب اتخاذ تدابير صارمة
لمنع المزيد من الانتشار قبل
فوات الأوان ،
فمن الأفضل القيام بذلك الآن ومن
ثم الاستعداد لرفع الحظر في أي وقت إذا كانت هناك
علامات  يتحسنون في الصين بدلاً من
عدم القيام بأي شيء وانتظار كيفية
التحرر ثم فرض الحظر ، وهو
شعور يشاركه العديد من سكان هونج كونج
ويعتقد أولئك الذين يزورون المدينة
أنه يجب عليهم التوقف
عن دخول هونغ كونغ مثل الأشخاص من الصين القارية
لأنهم  استمر في إحضار
الفيروس إلى هنا ، وأعتقد أنه يجب عليهم
منع وصول الصينيين
إلى هونغ كونغ ، حسنًا ، في الوقت الحاضر ، فإن
الفيروس خطير للغاية ولا نريد
أن يأتي كل الفيروس من ووهان إلى
هونغ كونغ ويؤثر على الناس.
يطالب العديد من الأشخاص
بإغلاق الحدود بالكامل ، بل إن بعض العاملين في المجال الطبي
يهددون بالإضراب إذا
لم يحدث ذلك
عندما سئل الرئيس التنفيذي كاري لام
يدافع عن الإجراء الحالي  عينت
الرئيس التنفيذي ، قلت إن
السلامة العامة هي شاغلك الأساسي ،
ولكن عندما تحدد التدابير التي تتخذها ،
فإنها تبدو وكأنها
نصف إجراءات ، هل تعرض
حياة سكان هونغ كونغ للخطر من خلال عدم إغلاق
الحدود هناك كبيرة  عدد سكان هونغ
كونغ الذين يسافرون الآن
في البر الرئيسي وفي الخارج ويحتاجون إلى
العودة لذلك لا أعتقد أنه من
المجدي جدًا التحدث عن
إغلاق كامل لنقاط مراقبة الحدود
وهذا يعني حدود هونغ كونغ مع
البر الرئيسي  سيبقى مفتوحًا جزئيًا
مما يجبر الجميع بما في ذلك
أصغر سكان هونغ كونغ على حماية أنفسهم
بليك إيسيغ سي إن إن هونغ كونغ